so this pitch clock is this the first
season they're implementing that yes
guys the minor league guys have
experienced it but yeah so I kind of
want to process that like where you're
at with this thing because you know
baseball you know America's past time
the legacy of baseball past time using
that word intentionally these days the
biggest sport in America is football
basketball kind of has the biggest icons
if you will the bronze Steph Giannis
you know Baseball's all about tradition
you know growing up I was all about
baseball that was all I was at you know
honoring the Legacy the past Babe Ruth
Mickey Mantle everything Ty Cobb how
much do you think this pitch clock is
going to change the game and not honor
the past time that was baseball yeah
there's a lot there's a lot to it I mean
even when you when you talk about the
pitch clocks you talk about the uh
analytics and I'm kind of in the middle
of ground there I'm not in the high end
of it or you know push it to the side
it's going to change a little again now
because you can't play you can't do the
shift so my kid that's playing second
his feet his feet both feet have to be
on the dirt
um you can't be playing you know having
four outfielders or having a second
baseman play just about right field
um Pitch clock the main thing and that
uh again I preached it to two teams when
I leave here again I'm gonna tomorrow
I'm gonna talk to Houston and uh the
main focal point will be I think it's a
focus thing now because you're speeding
up and it's going to turn a pitcher into
a thrower because all you're going to do
is look at the catcher get the sign real
quick and here we go I'm heaving it and
you're going to make a lot of mistakes
in the strike zone or you're going to
throw some pitches without really
uh uh you know being behind that pitch
mentally and focused on where you want
to throw it so I I think it'll make
again there's a couple pictures that are
wearing The Wristband that are calling
their own game I called 90 95 of my game
from the mound just with my looks
um with my catchers had some wonderful
catchers you always give them guys props
over 24 years had some fantastic
catchers that paid attention to detail
and if one of those Sketchers got traded
to another team and we're playing them I
I couldn't they knew they knew my
Cadence and what I was doing with my
eyes and which side of the plate I
wanted to throw the baseball on but uh
again I think the main thing about the
pitch clock is that guys are just going
to start grabbing a ball get a sign and
throw it without understanding how
you're trying to break a hitter down do
you think here's where I'm going with
this Roger
um do you think that this is something
that's inevitable meaning like listen
you gotta evolve that's just kind of how
Sports work hey you gotta adapt with the
times you know and it's a good thing you
know the only thing constant is change
or the other end of the spectrum sign of
the times you look at gen Z these days
or even younger kids you know elementary
school and all that their attention span
is so limited right you know if you
don't get someone's attention in three
seconds five seconds whether it's tick
tock or SnapChat they just can't pay
attention they're not going to sit
through a three and a half hour baseball
game or it's a pitcher's duel and it's
1-0 going into the ninth and they're
just like they want it quick they want
it fast this this sort of instant
gratification there's sort of the good
bad and ugly of this what are your
thoughts again you've got kids in their
20s 30s and you've been up you said you
had grandkids right yeah the grand boy
so you've got a good perspective on Age
and and generations yeah I mean it's
just like you said but with like like
football when I talk to the college
football players I mean coaches they
they gotta let music blare in the
clubhouse now and they got to have
everybody's got a TV in front of their
locker with their swag and their
highlights on it you just got to kind of
roll the roll at the Times a little bit
with these guys
you want to speed up baseball he said
get rid of the walk-up music and
everything else but that's that's it
that's baseball baby you got your walk
up music everybody's dialing and popping
their collar and now you know I I
pitched right through it I mean the
early days in the early days if you hit
a bomb and you flipped your bat oh yeah
do that to Nolan Ryan or Bob Gibson and
see if you're even alive to play the
next game straight up I mean it those I
mean that was you know I'm jumping
around here my my uh Don Drysdale
uh uh uh story was I was 22 years old I
just pitched in Winter Haven I was with
the Red Sox I pitched my three Innings
against the Dodgers were in town
obviously and and big Don Drysdale was
doing his radio show I knew the name I
didn't know him I'd never met him
six foot five our PR guy goes when you
get done icing Don drysdale's outside by
the batting cages like to interview for
a show
so I got there meet him he's a giant of
a man and I mean you're not small yeah
I'm about he he was six you know he had
me buy a full inch and uh and so I go um
uh soft Spoken Man we go through 20
minutes his radio show and he turned his
radio off and then this this this
different voice came out and it's like
let me tell you something kid he goes
I've watched you got a chance in this
game I go thank you Mr Drysdale he goes
you know what my best damn pitch of the
game was kid I go no sir Mr driving now
I'm kind of shaking like the Tin Man a
little Mr Drive oh yeah oh yeah I'm 20.
so I'm kind of I'm kind of got the Tin
Man shaking going on looking at the eyes
here and uh he goes you're my best damn
pitch of the game was son I said no sir
he said it was my uh he said it was my
second knock down pitch you know why kid
he said because then the hitter knew the
first one an effing mistake and I was
like yes sir Mr dry and I ran I ran out
of there and uh but that that's that's
the old school guys yeah but uh yeah so
I think It's Entertainment you know
we've got the cheerleaders now and the
dugouts you got your walk up songs the
guys you know uh now now I've kind of
moved to
um if you don't like the way things are
going play better
um if you don't like the guy flipping
his Bat you know keep the ball out of
the middle of a plate you know you kind
of you're the one that hung it but
um
uh you know like I said I I agree with a
lot of the um the analytics I I get it
but you still have to have an eye and a
heart test you know it was great for me
even at my Advanced age I was in my 40s
and say with the Yankees male stodemars
my pitching coach and I would come off
in the seventh inning and I was grunting
out there and you could tell that I was
laboring a little bit and he grabbed me
he's like you know Joe they want to they
want to move to the bullpen and because
it looks like you're emptying your tank
but Mel and I had a little system that
now I go one hitter at a time so I'm
going back out for the eighth knowing
that if this guy gets a base hit or gets
on I'm coming out so my eight warm-up
pitchers are more intense and now I'm
really grinding on it now I get him out
the best closer in the game Mariano
Rivera only has to get four outs now
boom I get enough I get a pop-up now
he's only got you know so that's kind of
how we operated there instead of just
you know dragging somebody out of the
game right away so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]